hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and today i want to take you
through some really exciting and
interesting games
from the first day of action at the us
women's championship
it was a tumultuous tumultuous day
at the us women's championship today
with a lot of the players
having a lot of decisive results and
we're going to see a couple players
tonight that actually had only decisive
results
never drawing a game and the player i
wanted to start with here
is annie wang annie wang is actually
leading the tournament after one day of
play
she's the only player to get to two and
a half points out of three
there are a myriad of players following
her with two out of three but she is the
only one
to get two and a half out of three and
in this game
she was up against emily nuen who of
course is also having
a pretty interesting tournament here uh
a lot of wins and
one or two or i think just one loss here
against annie wang and we're gonna see
another game of emily's later tonight
and maybe that game goes better for her
but here
she's up against annie wang and let's
see what happens she goes d4
and he responds knight f6 knight f3
keeping
it simple not really committing to
anything
uh you see you see players play knight
f3 earlier and earlier these days
sometimes even before
c4 as in this game mainly because
you know the standard c4 e6
knight c3 d5 this is sort of seen as the
ideal queen's gambit for white in many
cases
but of course this allows the nimzo
indian which these days fewer and fewer
players with the white pieces are happy
to allow
so you see players play knight f3
instead not yet committing the knight to
the c3 square
for the purpose of getting black to
commit to something in the center
before allowing this bishop out to b4 in
this game we see
e6 c4 d5 and now only after d5
white plays the move knight c3 and is
bishop b4 still a playable move
well of course it is this is just there
were goes in defense but now the point
is that a lot of annoying nimzo indian
lines have actually been avoided
by having black commit to this pawn on
d5
and as we'll see in the game perhaps
white has a few extra options
thanks to this diagonal being open and
what black having committed to this pawn
on d5
to start with we see c takes d5 e takes
t5
black definitely needs to take back with
the pawn to maintain control over this
e4 square
and now white immediately goes out with
the move queen a4
check which at first glance seems to
attack two pieces
at the same time which is pretty scary
thankfully for annie wang there is a
response to this and that response is
the simple move
knight c6 blocking the check and
defending the bishop
so with knight c6 in mind why is white
actually coming out with queen a4
and giving this check well of course c6
while is the most well it is the most
natural square for the knight
black doesn't actually have the optimal
setup here
that is because this knight is blocking
in this pawn on c7 of course this pawn
would love to go
either to c6 to to support this pawn on
d5
or out to c5 to actually pressure
white's center
on d4 with the knight on c6 though this
pawn is stuck for the moment
and black's pieces might find a little
bit of awkwardness because of this
white continues development with bishop
g5 getting the bishop outside the pawn
chain before playing e3
and pinning this knight to the queen
black goes ahead and castles
the main move is actually h6 but we'll
see black transpose after castling first
e3 played and now black does play the
move h6
and i'm not so sure that there's really
any reason for one move first over the
other
um i don't think emily really missed any
opportunity to punish this move order i
think it's just a direct transposition
and here we're gonna see white make a
very interesting decision
so there is a choice in front of the
player with the white pieces
do you preserve this bishop something
like bishop h4 or bishop f4
or do you trade this bishop with bishop
takes f6
um fans of the analyzer games class that
we do on twitch
later tonight well will know that i have
had some things to say about bishop
takes f6
in other positions but the question
remains
for this specific position is it a good
idea to take on f6
or not what should white be looking to
do here and i turn it to you chat room
what do you think bishop takes f6 or
bishop h4
or bishop f4 which of these moves appeal
to you
manny says takes looks good because
queen can't take
so i assume manny is referencing the
pressure on the d5 pawn
but i will have you pull note that
knight takes d5
is literally illegal so bishop takes f6
black likely will be responding with
queen takes f6
also congrats to manny who got to two
thousand only chess today
so we can call him a graduate of the
class maybe maybe we can
maximiliano says it's too complicated
well
let me show you what emily played in the
game and we'll see if it matches up with
your intuition here
at first glance probably most people's
first reaction is to preserve the bishop
but here emily actually does trade the
bishop for the knight and she does
so for a very specific reason uh bishop
takes
and queen takes played in the game and
what is the reason
that emily gives up this dark squared
bishop well
she's actually playing to pressure this
d5 pawn just a little bit
why is she playing this way well because
it makes sense with her previous play
with queen a4 check forcing the knight
to c6 now the d5 pawn cannot be
very comfortably supported by a pawn on
c6
so by removing this knight which defends
d5 for this bishop which can't attack d5
emily is successfully increasing the
pressure against this
d5 pawn something else that she's doing
is she's actually relieving
the pressure of this pin just a little
bit if this bishop were to retreat to h4
you very much have to contend with the
idea of g5 bishop g3
and knight e4 now all of a sudden
there is in fact pressure on this knight
on c3
if you play a nonchalant move perhaps
rook c1 just defending the knight
you might get hit with a stunner h5 and
what does h5 do
well all of a sudden h4 is a threat and
this bishop
is trapped it's not so comfortable by
the way to play a move like h4
when knight takes g3 and f takes g3
eight
is going to ruin your structure and
quite possibly your entire weekend
so no bishop h4
today no bishop f4 today largely because
these 94 threats are strong but also
because bishop takes f6
is perfectly consistent with the way
that white has been playing increasing
the pressure
on d5 in the game white now completes
development with bishop e2
we see bishop e6 and now white
actually asks black to make a decision
with her bishop the same question that
was asked to
the player with the white pieces is now
being asked to the player with the black
pieces do you trade this bishop
or do you keep this bishop and the
answer to this question
is actually pretty interesting so
without a doubt the most popular option
is to end up giving up
this bishop for this knight likely
because it really does alleviate a lot
of the pressure on the queen side and
this can be done actually in two
different ways
first of all the most direct ways to
play bishop takes c3
b takes c3 follow this up with a6
and likely black is looking to play
something like b5
get control of c4 and while the black
structure on the queen side can be a
little bit suspicious
it's not so easy for white either with
this pawn back here on c3
rather than on b2 when it can be used in
minority attack
another alternative that is actually
slightly more popular is to go bishop d6
but this actually runs into a very
powerful move by white which is the move
knight b5
when all of a sudden this bishop might
not be surviving the game after all
the most popular way to play here is
bishop g4
and white can sort of take this bishop
whenever she desires
in the game this didn't happen at all so
i won't say in the game
but one potential continuation is rook
to c1
knight e7 knight d6 queen d6
queen b4 and this is a pretty well known
end game line where white can go b5
fixing the doubled pawns
and black is thought to be about equal
here now in the game
annie came up with door number three and
this is something that actually
is not totally a novelty it has been
seen once or twice before
but is very very much not the standard
way of treating the position
she says why am i giving you my dark
squared bishop i'm gonna keep this guy
and she brings it back all the way to e7
now what's the problem with this
obviously the e7 square is not the ideal
square for the bishop
on d6 it pressures the white king's side
quite thoroughly
and that is sort of what black is
playing for
in the game here white has a good
structure on the queen side
this knight has made black structure
rather awkward there's pressure on d5
these pawns both sit undefended and
white is going to look to take advantage
of this
whereas black on the other hand is
largely looking to use these
open bishops on these open diagonals and
pressure the white king's side
so what is bishop e7 you know why keep
this bishop at all if it's not going to
be useful
in the attack well let's see what idea
annie wang had in mind
emily starts with the move kingside
castles and now i would like you guys at
home
to try and find annie wang's idea here
what is annie
trying to do with bishop e7 see if you
can find
some way to make this bishop useful
it's a pretty surprising idea
manny says maybe get it to c7 later and
the problem with that
is that you just don't have time right
you don't have time to do many things
on this queen side here if you try
something like bishop d8 maybe hoping
knight e7 c6 bishop c7
the problem is you immediately are
running into moves like queen b5
when guess what that is actually just a
fork
two pieces are attacked at the same time
tough to defend both of them
this pressure on the queen side is is no
joke here it's no joke
and great wolf actually has the correct
idea here this is
annie's idea in the game she does in
fact want this bishop on this diagonal
because it is the best
diagonal for the bishop it pressures the
white king's side she wasn't disputing
that when she brought it back to e7
she was merely of merely avoiding knight
b5 i don't know why i can't say that
word but i can't
she was avoiding knight b5 which would
be effectively capturing this dark
squared bishop the bishop can't move
because of the pressure on c7
so she drops it back to e7 for a turn
and then she plays this move a6
it's the idea of a6 well for one you
stop these nasty queen b5 threats
and number two you are actually stopping
knight b5 as well
and we see after white's next move the
natural b4
going for the minority attack black
brings this bishop back to d6
and after these two slightly
you know very natural moves but not the
most aggressive moves of all time by
white
black is very much doing okay in this
position
it feels as though white maybe missed an
opportunity to apply the pressure a
little bit more quickly after bishop e7
because if black is allowed to actually
keep this bishop on d6
then she's going to have very very good
play against this white king's side as
we'll see in the game
so backing up just a couple moves here
let's say
instead of kingside castles white had
played queen to b5
i'm not entirely sure sure what annie
actually had planned in case of this
maybe even something as active as
bringing the bishop back to d6
immediately
which is of course a pretty crazy pawn
sacrifice if queen takes b7
probably knight e7 and white is in fact
just up a pawn here
but of course there is still this nasty
pressure
on the king side and if knight takes d5
maybe something like queen g6 when again
black is just playing for this kingside
activity
playing to make some threats on this
side of the board very nice
idea for a rapid game that being said if
black doesn't go for this bishop d6 idea
here there's still no way to defend both
of these pawns and i think probably this
is what white should have gone for
in response to bishop e7 and i would
imagine
this is why we're not seeing bishop b7
played at sort of higher levels
or even just played more often because
you know a pawn is a pawn it's not so
easy to give those guys up it's like
uh you know if you give up this pawn you
you better be sure you're getting a lot
of activity for it
but in the game white played it a bit
too slowly king's side castled we saw a6
by black
and now after bishop d6 black is once
again doing
just fine in this position queen b3 was
a natural move by emily again
just applying some pressure to the d5
pawn and now black
starts to try and fix her queen side
structure
by rerouting this knight to a more
attacking position on the king's side
allowing these pawns a little bit more
mobility no nasty knight on c6
stuck in front of them now white
continues with the move knight a4
aiming to control this c5 square quite
thoroughly
and in the game i'm
not the biggest fan of how annie decided
to treat it i'm not saying what she did
was bad by any means but i think here
knight c5 is a big enough threat that i
personally would have liked to just play
the move b6 here
stopping knight c5 outright um or
is it actually because there's still
these ideas but
still at the same time i think b6 was in
black's best interest to stop
knight c5 and at worst she can regain
her pawn back on c5 here in exchange for
the bishop
but okay no b6 in the game instead she
just goes rook 88 but now after knight
c5 she has to play this
bishop all the way back to c8 which is
not the end of the world
but is maybe not totally ideal that
being said i'm being a little bit overly
critical here black again
is still doing just fine it's more just
personal preference i
would have liked b6 with a little bit
more clarity leaving this knight here on
c5
just feels a little bit a little bit uh
scary to my eyes
in the game rook f to c1 was played
white again
playing for pressure on the queen side
and black again
should be going for ideas on the queen
on the king side here
she first activates the final rook
though bringing it to the e8 square with
some pressure
on this bishop on e2 and you might be
thinking this move is a little bit more
mysterious than the the past few moves
black has played
you know is the rook really so much
better on e8 than f8 shouldn't i be
doing
more active things on the king's side
and you would have an argument there
although we'll see a little bit later on
this rook is a very very relevant piece
this rook isn't doing nothing on the e8
square
it's it has more than one idea of just
rookie six rook g6 right you know this
idea is a little bit far-fetched
but that's not all this rook does it
guards e4
and on rare days it attacks an e3 pawn
which may come in handy
a4 played in the game for white again
going for this minority attack
and black plays the move knight f5
we continue with b5 and i'll talk about
knight of five
in a moment here but first white is
making some threats on the queen's side
and once again black is faced with a
decision how do we
meet this b5 advance we have
you know quite a few options here just
to name a few option number one
take that dude get them off the board
option number two
push past that dude leave him on the
board
option number three i don't care what
white's doing i
am going to go checkmate this king moves
like knight h4 moves like g5
let me add him so what do you think chad
which should be played in this case
chess king likes a5 to close the
position
fair enough manny likes b6 a5 it's a bit
too
too late for that of course it's a bit
too late
the time to play b6 has gone great wolf
likes option number three
uh specifically in order to play like a
psycho
cowboy which is always fun always fun
and
the third person to speak in the chat
has chosen the
option not yet chosen which is a takes
b5 so the chat room is pretty much
pretty much split on this one pretty
much split on this one
so a few people just want to attack
quickly and
a couple people like a5 and uh
a takes b5 still only has the the one
voter
and really these three branches at this
moment i think objectively
are all okay for for black you can
really take your pick
on on this one the question you have to
ask yourself is
practically which one is giving my
opponent the the tougher time
and i think in fact a5 is giving the
opponent the
the toughest time right a5 is the kind
of move
where it it is effectively slowing down
white's counter play
and when you do effectively slow down
the opponent's counter play
they have to start making some decisions
right if you just sort of launch
with g5 or something white you know
doesn't really have to make any decision
here
white's like okay fine i'll go b takes
a6 start opening things up
and and play to win on the queen side of
the board
right you sort of make the decision for
white in the case of a move
like g5 if you take on b5 again
you are not really forcing your opponent
to make decisions
a takes b5 is a very natural move by
white and then white's going to follow
it up by invading with the rook
either to a8 or a7 and perhaps dropping
this knight back getting the other rook
in the game
and again the play is going to be very
very natural for
white whereas when you play the move a5
as annie did in the game i think this is
a great practical idea
because now it's not so clear what
white's plan is on the queen's side
white has a little bit more work due
work to do here to determine how she's
planning to actually break through this
structure
for black which is why i think
practically a5 is a really really great
idea
so a5 played in the game not that
there's anything too objectively wrong
with a move like g5 or even a move like
a takes b5
it's just that it makes white's play a
little bit more clear gives white a
little bit more clarity
which is something that i tend to uh to
really like avoiding
in the game knight d3 played by white
still a very nice move
opening up this rook and rerouting the
knight to some more
happy squares in the center or on the
king side where the knight can both
serve as an offensive piece as well as
maybe a much needed
defensive piece and here black's idea of
knight f5
sort of comes a bit more clear she
wanted to go
knight h4 why did she want to go knight
h4 she wanted to kill this knight on f3
why does she want to kill this knight on
f3 because this knight is always a very
good defender
guarding this h2 square and threatening
to jump into e5
in many many variations so knight e7
to f5 to h4 is just a classic idea to
get rid of a defender around white's
king
white goes ahead and captures black
captures back we see
g3 now this is the setup that white
chooses
to sort of combat black's kingside play
we see this queen come back to f6 which
makes sense
black has provoked a few weaknesses
around this king now
and so she's happy just retreating and
regrouping while she determines the best
path forward
and now white comes up with a really
really interesting idea
like i said if you sort of take your
time here it's not really clear
how white is exactly planning to break
through on this queen side
black is probably going to avoid playing
the move like b6 which gives white the
c6
square so for the moment these two
squares seem off limits
to blacks p to whites pieces and it's
really really unclear
how exactly white is going to break
through
as i keep saying and in the game emily
found the interesting idea of just
playing
b6 outright and b6 is a pretty committal
move
of course in this case black's only
option is is pretty clear here
c takes b6 would open things up far too
much on the queen side
this is where black wants to keep things
closed so annie of course immediately
plays
c6 so what do we think about this move
b6 by emily
do you guys in the chat sort of see the
idea
um on the one hand you clarify the
situation
on the queen side you allow black to
keep things closed on the c and the b
files this b pawn is never really going
to move unless of course something awful
happens to the b7 pawn
but what is white getting in exchange
for it what is the benefit here
what is the benefit and yeah manny
is catching the right idea here it's
this a5 pawn this a5 pawn
is a little bit touchy over on the queen
side
for black it's not easy to defend and
with this white pawn now on b6 it's
pretty unclear how black is planning to
defend this guy
after the move queen c3 now the downside
for white
is that an a5 pawn is all the way over
on the a file right and white's king is
on the
g file so if we look the a file
on the right and the king on the left
these two places are pretty far apart
and if white starts spending time
capturing pawns on a5 she might find
herself having a little bit of an issue
with her king and if black had played
the move
queen g5 this is surprisingly the most
accurate move i i would
be pretty impressed if the players had
found this in the game with the queen
just moving back to f6 and now up to g5
queen takes a5 would actually be a
pretty serious mistake here
so who sees why black to move and sees
the advantage
in this position
wasn't immediately queen g5 better well
we'll take a look at it but for now
let's look at this position with the
queen on g5
what is happening here
and yeah chess king is doubtful of his
own idea but it is the correct idea in
this case
rook takes e3 it's just a very very
powerful move
and that's why i said this little
mysterious rook move here it does
occasionally
come come quite in handy for the black
pieces
and also eyes by the way a very weak
bishop on e2
so not so easy to meet this move by
white if you take on e3
you do in fact just straight lose after
bishop takes g3
when all of a sudden these two bishops
which are lurking in black's camp
suddenly are just checkmating the the
white king if you take this
then check king h1 and the simple move
bishop f5 is good enough to win the game
rook f1 is the only way to not get mated
and here eric d6
the last rook joins the fray and emily
would have gone down
in a glorious fashion so white has to
not take the rook and go something like
bishop f1
by the way if you take take and try not
capturing this piece
things don't really get better for you
something like bishop h4 check
and queen f6 things are just nasty nasty
nasty here
so that would have been a pretty
incredible uh move
but annie wang plays a slightly more
natural looking bishop f5
just bringing the bishop into the attack
as well and now white calls the bluff
she takes on a5 and now it's up to annie
to decide how to continue the attack
right she's sacrificed this a5 pawn
in order to draw the queen far away from
the king
and now she has to figure out how do you
actually make tangible threats
against the white king's side so what do
you think chad
how do you actually make tangible
threats against the white king what to
do here
turning it back to you again
by the way yeah notably all of these
attacking ideas
for annie are sort of made possible due
to the fact that she still has this dark
squared bishop on d6
so her opening little uh gambit i'll
call it because it was
sort of a risk to play bishop e7 when
mike has these good ideas like queen b5
her opening gamut has in fact paid off
here she's kept her bishop
and she has a nice little attacking game
manny says bishop e4 to provoke f3 i
think bishop b4 would be great if white
were forced to play f3 but of course
white is not forced to play f3 white can
likely
just retreat the queen back somewhere
to you know reasonable territory
and the game would continue
so i sort of have set your expectations
maybe a bit too high for black's
position
with this rookie 3 idea
really those types of sacrifices are
rarely going to work
against this structure for white unless
you are
just crashing through on the g3 square
rather immediately
white can sort of come back and defend
right so what do we need well we need
some way to break down this structure
for white
and the way to do that isn't actually
with peace threats
uh making threats with the pieces is
actually pretty difficult in this
position
right like bishop e4 queen h3 there's
just bishop f1
and that itself is hard to sort of
manufacture
and you know there's there's just no way
to make threats with the pieces here
like rookie six isn't really doing
anything
so the thing to do is introduce a pawn
into the attack with the move
h5 we use this pawn sort of as
you know our battering ram to crash
through on the g3 square
and soften up these squares around the
white king
now emily plays a very interesting move
she plays knight c5 just going directly
for activity against this black b7 pawn
annie of course continues with the move
h4 now
deciding it's perhaps time to defend her
king emily plays queen d2
adding some extra support to the e3 pawn
h takes g3 is very natural
h takes g3 and now we have
this position and
i do like the move that annie plays in
the game the engine
sort of uh says it's it's not the best
move ever
but i mean in a position like this i
think queen g5 is a very very human move
to make and i think it's perfectly fine
here you just bring the queen
into the attack against this g3 pawn and
give your opponent tangible threats to
solve
now in the game emily plays bishop f3
which is a very logical move
allowing the queen to defend along the
second rank and now annie
does actually have to make a rather
unfortunate move
as i've said unfortunate a few times now
she decided she has to take this knight
which i think is the correct call here
because otherwise this knight is just
taking on b7
and black is just losing the game
outright unless she has some crazy
checkmate
which in this case i don't think she
does so having to take this knight
gives up a lot of her pressure on the
dark squares but after rook takes c5
she still finds some way to keep the
attack going how should she keep the
attack going well of course
as i'm sure you guys in the chat no you
have to get the rooks into the game
so now that she has opened up this h
file allowing
her rooks to occupy it
she once again trades off a bishop to
slow down white's pressure and is now
going for the throat
white for her part is not intimidated by
this attack at
all and just plays the move a5 trying to
get counter play on the queen's side
rook h6 by annie wang is the natural
follow-up
queen e2 is emily's choice
guarding this bishop a little more
thoroughly
by the way if you don't play queen e2 if
you just pass for example
then perhaps bishop g4 was a little bit
of a threat when the queen could come to
h5
to follow so queen e2 stops any bishop
g4 ideas
and we see annie play a pretty
interesting move once again
which is queen g6 she's going for some
light squares around
the the queen some light squares around
the king not that move and
some potential queen h7 ideas as well as
invading on this diagonal
so just a nice little solid move sneaky
attacking move
presenting more options for her pieces
queen f1 is what emily chose in the game
and now bishop h3 for annie
the bishop comes back to g2 and the
bishop comes back to g4 so a little bit
of back and forth here by the players
they were getting pretty low on time
white continues with the move f3 now
which again
is is a pretty committal idea like
manny in the chat said if we could
provoke f3 from white that would be
great and that's exactly what
annie managed to do here by the way if
you don't play f3 if you play something
like h6 then queen h5 is sort of just
killing killing your king so f3 by emily
was a nice find in time pressure to keep
the game going
now queen h5 is the very active idea
by annie wang once again going for the
throat don't even think about touching
this bishop
queen h2 check rook f6 check and bishop
f3 is illegal
so your queen is dead
so queen h5 nice move king f2 by emily
again a nice move the both
both players finding really great moves
under time pressure this king needs to
evacuate
as soon as possible rook f6 was the move
that annie came up with to keep the
pressure on
queen h1 was again an accurate defensive
move by
emily guarding this f3 pawn with the
queen and offering the queen trade
queen f5 kept the pressure up for black
and now unfortunately emily does crack
under the pressure
as we have seen happen with numerous
players in this tournament
uh when the clock starts to starts
ticking down
right these players are capable of some
really incredible chess
as we've actually seen in this game but
once that clock gets below
2-3 minutes it gets very very tough to
keep playing your best chess
and here i think unfortunately emily
plays the move e4 and this i think is a
move she would like to have back
of course black can just capture this
pawn with the queen
the pin is maintained and everything now
is falling
around this white king and it is just
going to be checkmate shortly
queen d1 played queen e3 check king f1
bishop f3 and emily does resign
but let's take a second here before the
move e4
and see if we can find an improvement
for emily so white to move
and actually keep a very very nice
advantage
in the position see what you guys think
see what you think
not e4 says chess king and he would be
correct
a6 does keep the game going does keep
the game going
a6 is not bad
rook a2 i'm not sure i'm a fan of so
let's look at what happens if you play
some move
like like rook a2 right i
think black's idea maybe
g5 which is sort of crazy right sort of
crazy to expect g5
but i think black does have this very
nice attacking idea if black didn't have
this idea
i think white could sort of play
anything and just be fine but with this
idea things are a little bit tougher so
of course what's the point
well the point is bishop f3 and g4
and things are not so easy things are
not so easy
for white here if you play a7 for
example queen d3
and this is looking a lot like checkmate
looking a lot like checkmate
so i think white's best move in the
position is actually the move rook c3
with the idea that now after something
like g5 this rook
is doing a lot to defend the king
there's no queen d3 idea anymore
and the white king is going to stay a
bit safer you can follow this up now
with a6
and if black tries the same a7 for
example
now it's just a lot tougher to make any
tangible threats around this king for
example queen e4
is still trying but perhaps the king can
run away
with white just barely covering
everything
and now running out of threats black
will have to abandon the attack to stop
the a pawn
and white would of course be winning so
definitely
can't really fault emily for missing
this one i do wonder though if annie saw
this idea of g5 to keep the attack going
it's a really interesting one
and it would have been fun to see how
this game ended
if the players had a little bit more
time on the clocks
that being said annie kept her cool
under the pressure
and emily was the first to crack with
the move e4
which does just lose the game so really
impressive game from both of these
players
uh i really liked annie's opening idea
here with bishop e7
of course this move queen b5 by white
would have been an interesting idea to
try and refute it
but she just goes bishop b7 a6 bishop d6
says all right
i kept my bishop best of luck to you
best of luck
best of luck to you so really impressive
game
by annie and yeah for her part emily
played very very well
for the vast majority of the game and
then really did
just slip up with this last move here
so i am going to move along now to
another game and i felt like
it might be a good idea to take a look
check in
with our current us women's champion
i of course am talking about the one the
only
jennifer yu reigning champ coming in
to defend her title here against uh you
know a very very very strong field so
jennifer
of course was a bit of an underdog in
the tournament when she won
the title but uh we'll see if she can
actually defend her title this year
she's often not
the worst start in the world i think she
has uh
two points or one and a half i don't
know the standings are tough to keep
straight we're on like tournament number
four in october here i can't remember
the standings of all of them
but let's just look at this game that
she had against martha
simadeshvili so this game goes e4 c5
knight c3 so not the normal stuff so far
knight c6 knight f3 but then after e6 we
do
get an open type sicilian with the move
d4
cd4 and knight d4 so we are in
a paulson at this point
and this used to be a little bit of a
blind spot in my my
chest knowledge i never really got too
into all of the sicilians
then i did a 10 part series on the
nightdorf and i feel a little bit more
confident
talking about some of these things now
so we'll see how i do here we'll see how
i do
queen c7 and white plays
a very off beat move here of course you
know bishop p3 is main stuff bishop b2
you can fianchetto you can go f4 you can
even go
knight b5 you can even take this but
white chooses
the slightly strange looking move queen
to d3
so what is the point of queen to d3
well of course you get the queen off the
back rank introducing some ideas of
queen side castles you also defend this
e pawn a little bit more
thoroughly and you just gain a lot more
control
of a lot of light squares in the game a6
was played
keeping the knight out of b5 by the way
if you don't play
something like a6 white very much is
going to consider
going knight d to b5 now and
queen g3 is another big idea with
bringing this queen out
to to d3 you activate this queen
and put on some pressure white likely
isn't or black likely isn't going to be
very happy with
taking this guy because now there's no
comfortable solution to this idea
of knight c7 for example rook b8 means
bishop f4
and e5 means bishop g5 so some tricky
tricky stuff
from jennifer you to start off with
coming queen d3 with this nice
queen g3 idea as well as just general
control over the light squares
and black responds accurately with the
move a6
keeping the knight out of b5 altogether
and making sure these ideas
don't come to fruition we do see knight
takes c6 now though
and black really has her option of how
she wants to take this i think all three
captures are reasonable
but she chose queen takes c6 by the way
if something like b
takes c6 again we would likely see this
queen g3
idea come into play with white getting
the queens off the board and going for
some kind of end game
so queen c6 played instead now bishop b2
comes on the board
again queen g3 was playable but jennifer
decides against it
we see b5 by martha bishop out to f3 now
with some e5 ideas bishop b7
is martha's response and she's just
gonna meet e5 with queen c7
and call it a day although this is what
happens in the game
and maybe we'll see that this e5 pawn is
granting jennifer you a little bit of a
spatial advantage
so queen c7 jennifer trays off these
bishops
and just castles king's side
black goes 97 trying to complete
development and white goes knight e4
aiming for the slightly weak d6 square
and making use of this extra central
space with e5 pawn
knight g6 is the response by martha
going after this pawn and guarding the
square
now knight d6 would be a bit of a
mistake because
white really isn't interested in having
the queen here it's just going to get
evicted by rook c8 to c6
and a pawn on d6 is perhaps going a
little bit too far this pawn is likely
going to fall
as it is just a little bit too
overextended in the black's camp
so f4 instead keeps this pawn covered
and keeps the threats alive
we have bishop e7 bishop e3 white
improves her queen to c6
we say rook a to d1 and then castles
king's side
by black and we are arriving at
a middle game position here i think it's
safe to say both players
pretty much fully developed and we are
entering the middle stage of the game
so what do you guys think about this
position
what strikes you as interesting about
this one in particular
and what do you think both players are
going for just give me your general
thoughts on the position chat and we'll
talk a little bit
about about what you think and about
what i think and why you guys are wrong
and i'm right all the time
at least you know half the time maybe
isn't d7 hanging well you do have to be
on the lookout here
you take this guy i take this guy it's
tough
it's tough oh castles
so yeah the knight on e4 is a bit loose
have to be a little careful
of that one
white has space white does have space
white does have space
e4 knight looks iffy so interesting that
you guys are now focusing on
on this e4 knight so that is i think a
great way to kind of evaluate this
position
there are of course two things that that
should be pretty obvious right
queen white is of course trying to
pressure the d7 pawn
and black of course is trying to
pressure the c2 upon along the c file so
this is a very important factor
in the position taking a look at black's
play on the c file and white's playing
the d
file but on top of that you can usually
determine
how good a position is for a player by
the placement
of their minor pieces so do we like
whites minor pieces here or do we like
blacks minor pieces
this is i think a great way to at least
start evaluating a position
a great way to start and maybe
just maybe it'll lead us to the best
move
things we love says black black cat says
whites manny says whites
nightmares is white chess king says
white patrick daly says white
so i do in fact think white has some
advantage here
and the large difference is between the
knights
white's knight on e4 might be a little
bit loose but it does have very strong
you know jumps jumps forward right it's
controlling a lot of squares
whereas black's knight is sort of in a
pretty sad state here
on g6 however i think it does have
maybe one idea which is on some days it
can actually go knight h4
and over to g6 g4 might be playable for
white to try to keep him out
but you know g4 is a little bit over
committal right now all of a sudden
white is the one with the weak king and
you do have to be a bit cautious
so for that reason i think the best move
in this position
is actually the simple move g3 and i
think this is a really instructive idea
to to take away
the placement of the minor pieces is a
crucial crucial part of any early middle
game and in fact any position
in general and by taking advantage of
the fact that this knight is so
out of play uh white is able to prove
a pretty significant advantage in my
opinion for example
some of black's best tries now involve
going something like f6
and actually just giving up this bishop
for the knight
and giving up on the d7 pawn as well
and of course white has you know a
pretty substantial advantage here
queen takes c2 is playable but now
with very active major pieces and white
black's piece is still looking a little
bit uncoordinated
i think white should be a lot better in
this position
just one example continuation line rook
f to e1 queen takes b2 for example
and bishop d4 right so you can't even
take on b2 because of that if you go
queen c4
then let's say a simple bishop f2
queen a2 and gosh i don't know
just queen c7 rook d7 come take stuff
and yeah white's pieces are just more
active than blacks so i think white has
some advantage here
in the game though jennifer you decide
she's not afraid of knight h4 and just
goes rook f2
and that being said if black can't play
knight h4
then i think i definitely agree white is
maintaining the advantage here
for all the reasons that we just talked
about right
you know this this minor piece is just a
lot better than this minor piece and
it's going to show
uh eventually as we shall see so
why not knight g4 well perhaps martha
was actually a little bit concerned
about this
g4 idea or perhaps she thought that her
knight just didn't really have the
future that she wants
for it on the f5 square like best case
it's trading off
this bishop i personally think knight h4
would have been worth it for martha you
really have to get this knight back into
the game
and we'll see in the game that she just
doesn't quite get there
rick's ac8 played and now we see a
second reason why i do think white has
the better position
both players have their pressure against
their respective pawns on their
respective files
but only white is able to play this move
c3
black unfortunately cannot play d5 or d6
and so while white can go c3 and at
least slow down black's counter play
over here
black has no such options for the pawn
on d7
and i think this is yet another reason
why this
uh position is a little bit better for
white
queen c4 was played in the game and now
b3 by jennifer u forces the queen back
if you take on d3 i think you may end up
with a pretty big problem on the d7 pawn
for example rxc7 d2 rook d8 bishop b6
isn't going to be holding this guy and
so it's just tough
so queen c6 played instead now b4 was
played in the game
locking down b4 from black which would
of course
open the c file and now once again we
see white
sort of stemming black's play against
the c3 pawn making use of this
centralized knight
whereas black's minor pieces still not
doing a lot and this d-pawn is still
quite weak
rook fd8 is played and now jennifer u
makes a really interesting decision
and that is to go bishop c5 allowing
bishop takes c5 and knight takes c5
so what do you think of this move bishop
c5 by jennifer u
good move or bad move
good idea or bad idea doesn't it allow
d5
uh no d5 i can still play e takes d6
ties the rook down to f4 sure
sure sure bad d6 is weak
i'm a little confused little confused
what you mean chess king a little
confused
good d7 week so i think this is a bad
move and
you can look at it specifically and you
can look at it uh principally
oh you wanted to put the knight on d6
instead yeah
but i i don't think that's the most
relevant thing here
i think the most relevant thing here is
the principle this is violating is
trading pieces when you have extra space
and the specifics of it come down to
what a few people in the chat room are
mentioning
this knight did not have access to the
e7 square
and now it does and we see this knight
sort of re-enter the game
from g6 where it was effectively useless
it was effectively not
serving any purpose at all on g6
especially with g3
sort of coming whereas if white had
played a little bit of a slower move
here
something like work fd rick f2d2 just
keeping the pressure on
this guy on d7 something like queen b7
g3 giving white a little bit of time we
can
keep this piece effectively locked out
of the game and keep the pressure
on the d7 pawn and i would have much
rather seen
something like this from jennifer you
keeping this
knight out of the game not rushing
things quite so much and just keeping
the pressure alive
but after bishop c5 takes takes now the
knight does get back
into e7 but jennifer you is still
you know a little bit favored here
because she does have all this extra
space
even if she's now only playing against
one minor piece
rather than both of them so she
continues very actively with the move g4
which i definitely don't mind at all
now queen c7 and queen g3
routing this queen finally as we saw in
the opening
over to g3 with the same idea and she is
just going for the king side attack now
uh for her credit though martha now has
survived
to a point where she is able to play the
move d6
and get rid of this weak pawn on d7 and
this is sort of as a result
of uh jennifer you kind of giving up on
just locking the position
holding it down with moves like rook d2
and offering up this trade of bishops
now it's just too tough to keep all of
this pressure
on d7 with only one minor piece on the
board and martha is breaking free
and that being said pawn is a pawn
jennifer u
snaps on a6 and says i will take that
thank you very much
queen b6 is met with rick takes d6
takes takes and now if you take
my knight i will take your knight if you
move your knight i will save my knight
so queen takes d6 knight c5 and now
knight d5 is a bit of a misstep by uh
by martha but nothing too serious and i
think in this position
martha is actually doing just fine if
she plays a few active moves such as
queen d1 coming into queen
uh coming in to d2 after rook f1
something like queen d5 as well i think
is also fine
but knight d5 perhaps allows a little
bit of pressure on the d
file that being said i think black is
totally
totally fine in this position
white does have optically more space on
the king's side and more threats
but now one set of rooks has been traded
there's only knights on the board
the bishops are gone and i don't think
white really has enough firepower
to justify the weaknesses in her
position
right black has this one weak pawn on c6
but we see c3 could be weak
a2 could potentially be weak f4 is
potentially weak
and there is a potential weakness around
weights king as well
so i think here block has actually done
a very good job of sort of
getting out of the trapped looking
position that she was in
that being said though knight d5 once
again might be a little bit of a misstep
because queen d3
is quite strong putting pressure on this
queen and now after queen c7
white to move and once again uh play
for for the advantage white to move and
play for the advantage
i won't uh ask you guys for too long on
this one we are running short on time
but yeah patrick daly
immediately has the idea which is the
move f5 and i think practically this is
the best
that white can do now objectively i
think black is still doing okay
but practically definitely you would
rather be white after the move
after the move f5 right white is just
having all the threats
and black is gonna have to work pretty
hard not to let any of those threats
actually come crashing through now if
white had played
something like queen takes b5 knight
takes f4
at this point i think again it's going
to be anybody's game when
this is less about white attacking
black's king and more just about
these three pawns on the queen side
versus black's extra pawns on
the king's side and now once again it's
gonna be white who has to worry about
her king and practically that's just
never fun you would rather be the
attacker so i like f5
by jennifer yu knight f4 still comes
into the position
and now queen e3 e5 is trying to keep
things locked down
rook d2 though is now seizing the open
file
rook d8 is challenging that but now
finally once again
we see that the player who has been
under some pressure once
the clocks start to get low mistakes
start to be made
and who sees the problem with rook d8
who sees the problem
and yeah patrick daly has the answer
rook d8
unfortunately hangs the tactic of queen
takes e5
when now black is sort of helpless to
stop
dual threats right dual threats you
can't take the queen
because this looks a lot like checkmate
and you can't take
uh the rook because that hangs both the
queen and
and checkmate unfortunately martha found
the only way to keep the game going
which is knight h3 check
king f1 queen to c8
but now with the death of the e5 pawn
black is going to have a very tough time
in this position
especially without a rook to increase
the threats against white's king
jennifer u just pushes her majority
trades on f6 trades the queens and now
two pawns is two pawns
two pawns is two pawns a4
b5 king d6 b6
and martha resigns so pretty tough game
here
for martha she was under a lot of
pressure from the opening
and then just when she was beginning to
see the light just when she began
to come out with d6 and d5
freeing her position freeing her pieces
unfortunately
that is when the tactic was found by
jennifer yu it's when this f5 move
came and she just kept up the pressure
despite
martha glimpsing that light she could
almost reach out
and grab the draw but she could not it
it was just
not meant to be as jennifer you did an
excellent job playing good practical
chess and in my opinion that's the thing
we are seeing
from the u.s women's championship this
year as well as all the other
championships that have already finished
right
what's winning is not always objective
best chess but it is the best
practical chess that is prevailing the
practical players are having their time
to shine
especially in this rapid format online
format
that's where good practical solid chess
really comes in handy don't always need
to play the best move
you don't always need to play you know
the solid move
sometimes the tricky move is good enough
sometimes the aggressive move
just putting pressure on the clock on
the board every every place you can
is going to be enough to win the game
um okay so thank you all
so much for joining me here on the road
2000. the fun is going to continue
directly after this with the
end game class i would encourage you all
to tune in to that one and please
join me there i'm going to be going over
everything you ever wanted to know
and everything you didn't you ever
didn't want to know about opposite
colored bishop
and games that's right we're going to
start from the bare bones of it
and work up from there and eventually
hopefully if we have time
take a look at a really interesting end
game between the world champion magnus
carlson
and hikaru nakamura who doesn't love
looking at games between those two
so please go check it out that's it for
here on the road to 2000 once again
thank you so much for watching
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
you